good morning to you congratulations on
the numbers look when you go from here
with this business you've got a new
movie that's that's gonna be made you
are broadening the base in terms of the
products that you're offering you're
changing the demographics and the gender
story when it comes to the lair offering
as well I can you continue with this
pace of growth are you able to up this
pace of growth well I think in all
likelihood we'll see the growth rate
come down somewhat we can still continue
with a very healthy growth rates but we
are a company that is only growing
organically so we never really make
acquisitions because we want to stay
very true to the legal break the legal
brand I think that's really what makes
us very unique as a company and that
uniqueness gives us a global appeal that
applies equally well in Beijing or
Berlin or or Boston and that's why we
need to stick to it now I am confident
that we can continue to grow because the
global middle class is growing if I look
at the company in an 80-year history
then we seem to be growing roughly with
the growth in that local household
income so as the world continues to grow
as new markets developed particular in
Asia and other emerging markets the
legal brain will also continue to grow
helped by the new media and data lines
ation but sticking to the legal brick
jörgen I mean it seems to me that we're
talking actually about it was guy
earlier I mean it seems that we spent
both our weekends just building Legos
with our children but when you look at
the figures today you know 12% top-line
growth deflationary world and then that
margin 33.9% of operating margin how
difficult is that going to defend these
numbers are really spectacular at the
moment yes obviously I think we are
there sort of a sea need almost I am
extremely proud that it is our tenth
consecutive year of organic growth so
I'm mindful that of course one should
never be complacent but I do try you
know as a privately held company owned
by just one family to not focus too much
on disappointing on financial
performance but really stay focused on
not disappointing on stakeholders so for
me the retailer is a super important
partner and they need to be making money
selling like Oprah
our consumers need to recommend us even
more and we do measure that as well as
in terms of a Net Promoter Score and we
want our staff to be highly creative
motivated and engaged and we measure
that as well and that's really where I
focus my attention to make sure we never
become complacent and can continue to
reinvent ourselves and then I hope with
that in mind we will also continue to
see some some awesome financial numbers
as well how dependent are you on on this
sort of the creativity of others though
to make this work
minecraft you've got minecraft Lego
which seems like such a logical fits in
so many ways
frozen Star Wars etc etc I you seem to
obviously you've got great licensing
people and they're doing a good job but
but is there there kind of is there the
creativity stream in front of you that
you can latch on to to really take
advantage and keep the growth rate going
as well well well first of all I think
it's important to say that the mainstay
of our sales is on products that we
develop ourselves entirely in and are
based on the creative idea of the Lego
brick now that idea is so appealing that
when people develop other great creative
stories and properties such as frozen or
Minecraft the Star Wars their first port
of call for a commercial partner in the
toy market is always the legal brand
because it is the leading and most
popular brand in that market so they
come to us with their ideas and then
with some of them such as minecraft or
Star Wars we have a fantastic creative
dialogue which means that we inspire
each other in terms of developing the
property going forward and I think it's
fair to say that thanks to the legal
brain Star Wars has now been introduced
to several generations of children
because we were actually those
children's first experience with the
Star Wars brand remember there's a movie
coming out later this year but it is the
first movie in many many years and in
the meantime the legal brand has kept
Star Wars and major brand in the world
of entertainment it's true as these kids
get younger they forget the classic
jörgen give us a sense of what you went
through some of the toys that are doing
well but regionally what's very hot
right now so who's buying more like
and obviously again on the toys is the
tie-ups of the Star Wars or is it
products that are for example catered
more to to girls that are ahead of the
game well the growth is actually very
broad-based we're seeing Airlines like
Lego create a lego technic which are
sort of super classic Lego Lions doing
extremely well with height operated
growth rates but we're also seeing Star
Wars remaining very popular and growing
we see a lego duplo our preschool
offering is one of our top five lines
and so is LEGO Friends our theme
particular relevant for girls
so it's Apes it's broad-based and also
in terms of the global spread it's very
good we've seen you know in a place like
Sweden which you'd say that must be a
very mature market we've seen a
double-digit growth rate also in Belgium
and also in the UK and in the US but
certainly in places like China we've
seen more than 50 percent growth and in
Russia we've seen 35 percent 35 to 40
percent growth rate so I'd say the
growth is also broad-based and I think
the explanation to that is one this is
really a globally appealing brand it's a
global assortment we're selling kind of
like a few other major iconic global
brands and then secondly you know I
think the children are children
everywhere they do have different
influences some children have not heard
about Star Wars but fundamentally
child's play is the same in most
countries around the world and and
interestingly parents also value the
same learning and benefits from playing
in different cultures so when I meet a
Chinese mother she talks about the same
aspirations for her child the same value
from playing for her child as their
American or a German mother would do
just one final well two final questions
here then when am I going to be able to
buy a lego Oscar and is the Emmet
character behind you stuck together in
any way with glue no so the answers our
last one is of course no we don't build
mortals that lude if they're built by
legal frames they always made really but
I think unfortunately the image figure
here behind me is made by my marketing
department so there's probably a steel
structure inside to make sure it can
travel the world and be displayed in
stores but regarding
the league was at that big event that
happened a few days ago was actually
it's not created by us it was the
organizers who did that and they asked
their legal certified professional to
produce league oscars and I'm sure he'd
be happy to make one for you as well
yeah we need one we feel like I deserve
a body if you go on the internet you can
find me the PDF people have put together
how you do this yeah my question is how
long does it take for a simple tower
takes me a long time so a lego Oscar
yeah could take a while to take out a
weekend Jurgen congratulations thank you
very much indeed for spending so much
time with us this morning Jurgen victim
is still the CEO of Lego